- YEAH, YOUR SON WAS IN
A PRETTY BAD CAR ACCIDENT.
- PLEASE, JUST TELL IT TO ME
STRAIGHT, DOC.
- OH, OF COURSE, PARDON ME.
REGARDING YOUR SON, I FEAR
I DON'T HAVE ANY GOOD NEWS.
- OH, MY GOD.
- I MEAN, HIS ORGANS
ARE ALL [bleep], BRO.
- JUST TELL ME,
IS MY SON GONNA BE OKAY?
- WELL, CONSIDERING
THE STATE OF HIS--
UH, WHAT'S IT CALLED?
- I DON'T KNOW.
- UH, THAT PART OF HIM
THAT IS MASHED INTO BITS,
UNRECOGNIZABLE MUSH--
- WHAT? I DON'T KNOW,
I HAVEN'T SEEN HIM.
- WELL, SPOILER ALERT.
[laughs]
- WHAT'S WRONG WITH MY SON?
- MM, WHAT IS IT?
OH, HIS HEAD...
♪ SHOULDER, KNEES, AND TOES
♪ KNEES AND TOES
- WHAT?
- ♪ HEAD, SHOULDER, KNEES,
AND TOES ♪
♪ KNEES AND TOES
♪ AND HIS EYES AND HIS EARS
- OH, MY GOD.
- ♪ AND HIS MOUTH AND NOSE
- NO!
- ♪ YOUR SON IS JUST MUSH NOW
- [sobs]
- ♪ SO G--MAKE ANOTHER BOY